[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
episode of Griffin with Griffin the back
at riffin studio
[Music]
but I'm excited to have this next guest
coming on right now good buddy of mine
so welcome to the podcast mr. Jeremiah
Watkins
[Music]
[Music]
Elizabeth's for 45 minutes straight oh
my great theme song for the show and
they you you came totally prepared for
the podcast he brought his saxophone
yeah just in case we don't know if we're
gonna get that crazy we when is it ever
adjusting case with a saxophone there's
always a just in case it's excellent did
you ever do light wood when you were
dating at first before you got married
would you just like have your saxophone
[Laughter]
just have dry eyes in the case that's
like the pulp fiction soup case
yeah pretty much that's what's in there
yeah it's a fashion phone it's a
saxophone I should I should read it that
clip went where where they're looking at
a saxophone yeah
what's good to have you on man and like
you've been in the podcast came a little
while right yeah I was I you know I
don't want to toot my own horn but I
feel like I was one of the people who
were really trying to push you to get
into the game those things I feel like I
was like I feel old it's really what it
is I feel like I was like having this
old-school mentality about podcasting
where I was like you know oh that's that
new thing is like it's like what people
first guys cell phones people like you
know no no I have a cell phone
yeah or Twitter nobody's gonna get on
Twitter that's not gonna that's not
gonna catch on about I think podcasting
was the same thing but it's just like
it's such a job as you know yeah like
I'm doing this all myself I don't have
like a nerd sitting here helping me I
don't you know I don't have which I need
yeah well I think that if you want that
for the show I mean I there's plenty of
people who listen to the show that
they're probably somebody that would be
stoked to be a part of it no I'm
like it I mean I get people that send me
emails like hey hey I want to be your
intern like you know I'm just graduated
I'm coming to LA and I'm like wow it's
but it's like amazing like full-on
resumes yeah and I'm like whoa chill I'm
just doing a little show out of my Bible
I of my place but I mean I get it I mean
it's like you know I got I'm gonna
eventually think about it but for now I
just wanted to get the feel of it like I
like I do these tutorials on YouTube
because there's so many good but you
could just Google anything on YouTube
yeah it'll be like a nine year old like
already I feel horrible I know so it's
like that part of it is like great but
yeah man you've been doing your you
bamboozled me on your podcast though you
got you guys should go watch that
episode of Jeremiah wonders I got to
have you back on with video oh yeah now
we now have sound effects of things I
always come on on like when it just
starts in its infancy right and then I'm
never on again now you're all fancy
Halle dude you're coming back let's book
it right now people been asking for it
it's gonna happen so it's like I feel
like we know each other but we don't
know each other right so like I like to
do on my podcast yeah I like to like get
people's story you know I mean yeah I
feel like you're one of those people who
I always in the back of the comedy store
hang out with or the improv where we're
at and we're always riffing it at the
back like usually before you go up
because I go on like wailing go on the
next day to spy you have a whiskey yes
exactly that goes no but uh so wig you
look because were you from originally
I'm from Kansas originally oh that
explains so much what what what reads
Kansas about me okay somebody from
Kansas you could just go alright and it
makes so much I got to say before we
continue that like now with your short
here and then the headphones holding it
back your nose I mean your normal your
noses I'm gonna have to edit your nose
down it's giant
we get this green screen on this I'm
just gonna put a green screen over the
nose and I put a smaller nose on damn I
had this great like luscious hair it was
like it really had added a different
character to your face and then you cut
your hair and then it's like as if when
they were cutting your ear they care
they added it you know depth and yeah
extra hair back in my nose to push it
forward
but anyway so they did right so you from
Kansas yeah so born and raised in Kansas
big family what's the deal older brother
younger sister I'll read your middle
child yeah when did you know you wanted
to be in the entertainment business was
that in Kansas yeah in Kansas I made
like like a realistic decision somewhere
in high school but before that I always
thought it was not obtainable because I
don't I didn't know anybody I don't have
didn't have any friends or family like
connected oh there was Oh got you got
you
was it was like so literally in high
school it's like a pipe dream really
you're just like I wonder if I could but
but you okay let's back up even further
than before you wanted to be like a
comedian or all that kind of stuff you
obviously you were a musician first huh
I was yeah yeah yeah I grew up doing
like choir and a band
oh wow yeah yeah so choir and I was the
only boy Alto what's uh the only boy
Alto yeah flexing these pipes on these
hoes out in these streets
you got that falsetto too
so you had like so you were like in glee
you were in Kansas Glee if there was a
Christian version the show Glee or very
closeted no no I love Jesus no he's
great he's kind of ripped of his II know
get those ABS it's nice so you're in
Kansas in the Bible Belt
yeah and you're think of it in the thick
of it yeah you're doing your music so
when did it wanted to transfer until I
wanted to be like a comedian wanted to
be like funny well already just always
funny yeah I would do like voices and
like little impressions and dumb like
mimics of like cartoons and stuff like
that growing up for other people right
and that's kind of how you make friends
early on is is you know doing
impressions of movies and stuff like
that but already funny like it's funny
the the people who become comedians the
the main difference between the people
who are funny in high school and the
people who like kind of move on in my
opinion right are you right and you work
at it and the people who were funny in
high school they were just if you look
back there just like repeating like
funny lines from movies and then you're
like oh they were just boring they just
knew how it did have decent timing with
other people's jokes yeah yeah yeah yeah
I know what you mean but you were the
funny guy yeah all right so you always
we were flaky nerdy kid lanky nerdy kid
just lots of limbs dude you won't you
know sports you wouldn't believe this oh
and I play tons of sports oh okay so you
were just well you were like at that
particular school you were like you know
oh dude I was an all-star that's cool
yeah I was I was first and everything
led the team and in in points for
basketball everything and then I went to
public school and I was like I want no
smaller fish in this bigger Fallon I
came white pretty much why the saxophone
I mean that's such a difficult
instrument I saw somebody playing it
when I was a kid and I it was a weird
thing where instantly I looked at I was
like what is that and my mom's like like
that's a saxophone no but I watch this
guy play it and instantly was drawn to
it I was like this is this is just a
cool instrument I've never like there's
one guy who played it like in church and
I was like this isn't a common
instrument in church this is wow this is
random so I wanted to start taking
lessons and stuff that's why I did it
took a license for years and just kept
up with it and see that's so interesting
that you were inspired like that it's
because I think
that's what's missing from schools and
stuff now and like you know kids are so
impression about that way if you like
expose them to things yeah you you like
it's like oh what's that and then all of
a sudden you're doing it in so many
years later you're still doing it yeah
it's kind of crazy cuz I've been coming
up on like 20 years of playing now Wow
yeah 20 years yeah Jesus Christ
I know so you okay so you're in Kansas
you're either you're the star athlete at
Christian school I know I mean do you
want to share any more accolades here it
sounds so sad I'm just saying that in
attendance oh you're the you're the star
player or whatever of your Christian
private school and I was going Kansas in
Kansas it keeps getting smaller there's
like 17 kids in the school total pretty
much I mean no it was a small school I
had in my if I would if I would have
graduated from that high school I think
I would have been in a class graduating
class of 2000 was super small like that
like the grade school is much bigger but
like it was one of those things where by
the time you got the high school people
kept leaving like by the time like if
you saw it through you know I understand
you'd like leaving the school in points
no like yeah so when did you leave
Kansas and decide that like like acting
comedy was gonna be the route that was
in 2009 I've lived in LA since July 2009
so I'm about to hit my 10 year oh wow
yeah so you came to LA from Kansas came
like I'm gonna make it into business yep
oh [ __ ] yeah what what brought that on
I thought about well I've been a huge
fan of sketch shows like Saturday Night
Live and MADtv and stuff like that grown
up and I looked up kind of like the
trajectory of some of my favorite cast
members and a lot of them started out as
second city so there was a second city
in Chicago that's like the main hub the
main one but for what I want to do I
wanted to act and I was like maybe I
could get in a commercial like I was
just like thinking I've always like done
like a lot of different projects and
stuff like that so
I was like la kind of seems like the
best fit for me so I'm gonna head out
there yeah that's what everybody thinks
yeah yeah what you're doing it I mean
it's like we're still out here I know I
know
still living the drool living it well
yeah but you also like you're out here
you're married you know yes this is like
you know so it's all bananas you're
actually you're actually doing the damn
thing but so when you came here what was
your first what was your first thing
like what was the first like you got
here you got our apartment whatever you
however you did your thing but what was
the first like okay I'm actually even if
you weren't in the business but you know
you know that you know I'm saying like I
remember the first time I performed it
to Comedy Store it was for a class yeah
but I still thought oh my god I'm doing
comedy like what was your first thing oh
well well so one of my first things that
like was it super memorable with the
Comedy Store before this okay no not as
a second but one super memorable moment
was I was doing a bringer show at The
Comedy Store in the main room and I
didn't know any better at the time that
you know those aren't yeah I know I know
what you're saying
you just have classes yeah yeah you're
just like you just think that that's the
proper route so you're like okay I'm
doing what everybody else is doing out
here hustling yeah so you know I brought
my 10 or 15 people or whatever was
asking people pleading with them as
Starbucks come please go to my show
please come to my show and I had a set
that night that was it was the first
time where I was like oh I killed you
know I mean that first feeling we were
like you you've heard about this elusive
monster yeah yeah like people laughing
at what you say yeah like what is that
feeling and I had a I had a great set on
the main room stage of The Comedy Store
and Leslie Jones was one of the poppins
at night because they they pepper in
real comics to make sure that the show
stays afloat because you know there's a
lot of rough comics who are just
bringing people and they don't really
have talent
was that a Vargas show was that Vargas
and Cathy show Michael Q show oh yeah
and so I had a great set and Leslie
Jones started to walk by me and as she
stopped turned around and she looked
right at me she goes you were funny and
she kept walking I was like
oh this is so cool one of the like the
real comedians told me I'm funny you
know I mean like that that's that was
one of the first times I felt like oh
I'm like making progress with stand-up
before that like I thought I was making
it doing like background work like on on
shows like I did like the CW's like 902
oh no oh really yeah I was like can we
find you there's like a viewing party
years ago and I was so proud of this I
cut together a video of the scenes of me
[Laughter]
it's it's an old YouTube video that the
pride isn't have that many views but
it's literally like I like there's a
scene going on and then like I want to
start to walk by and I freeze frame and
I'm like and it says Jeremiah Watkins on
it dude I was so proud it should be my
mom thought I was gonna get discovered
from background well like that's how
like supportive she's been along the
whole journey that's actually the only
way to make it I mean my mom was very
supportive yeah I totally get that it's
like you have to have that person that
when you say this is my dream this is
what I want to do and you have somebody
going no matter how far-fetched it is
yeah somebody going you could do a baby
oh yeah what do you need me to help you
I know you know I mean that's what my
mom was so I appreciate that my mom has
this running joke with me I'll just I'll
tell her that I have a show tonight it
can be literally the worst show like
whatever part of the country and she's
like tonight's gonna be the night you
get discovered she says that after every
conversation now did you okay so mom is
your mom still in Kansas yeah oh it was
okay is it does she say things like cuz
my mom even living in when she was
living in LA was still like you know why
don't you just call the Tonight Show
oh you don't I mean you could call yeah
you can get on hotline or something yeah
yeah she's dude I had to have a
conversation with with my mom about
saying stuff like that I had to I kind
of cuz they're unaware they don't
complete unaware so you have to teach
them like
as we learn along the way still doesn't
get it yeah so all like I've had to have
multiple conversations over the years
with my mom like kind of like I'll let
you know when something's important
otherwise you know like it's like you
get your hopes up too much there's too
much ups and downs like she'd be like
let me go home let me know about how
that audition went I go we have to stop
this because because yes there's you
going so many auditions that you never
get that like within three days she's
like so did you book it no like oh we
can't do this pressure yeah yeah when I
was coming up my mom I went to this
commercial audition and I'll never
forget it cuz the guy it was me and this
guy it was a black guy who was like
Carlton from Fresh Prince so he's like
very much like hey how you're doing you
know like you know weird weird bad guy
and so the guy in the commercial the guy
running the commercial Gulf okay guys
you know what you know what let's just
do this different can you guys you know
put some Street on it like could you put
a little stank stank on it yeah that's
what he was talking so I said to him
like I was like see more black is that
what you mean yeah yeah yeah yeah all
the weed here and you guys are like and
I was like okay I know you know I get
what he was trying to go for but this
guy was with man was just it wasn't he
he went to prep school or something you
know yeah he had no idea he was doing a
steroid
tear stereotypical version of a white
guy doing a black oh that's great he was
a black guy you know yeah but anyways I
knew we weren't gonna book this okay so
I was like this is soon as he started
going I was like this is it we're never
gonna get this but anyway I tell my mom
okay
my mom writes a letter to at the time
there was this magazine called backstage
so it was where you can find auditions
there it was an industry where she
writes a letter and they publish it oh
no I have it someplace still but they
publish it as she's talking about my son
went to this thing you know and I was
like you can't do that kind of yeah like
thankfully I was nobody nobody you know
me like I just was a
actor or whatever well I can imagine now
if I tell her something like Dennis you
think Mike's fun Eric Griffin bah bah
bah you can't stop I know my mom just
crazy my mom has written into the Ellen
Show and yeah it's to try to get me on
oh man yeah I know and it was the worst
part if it works like you show up you're
I guess I'm doing this this is because
that's why she'll see it Jeremiah's mom
Oh
mama's boy yeah and then like so she
wrote in and like of course it didn't
work and she's like I will never support
that woman she's like loyal don't fall
the letters she's like she's with people
and Ellen comes on this like let me tell
you a story about yeah she read and you
like your assistants like hey [ __ ] out
of here
okay so all right so you're here you're
in it you got to LA you did you had that
experience now but let me ask you when
you had that experience with Leslie and
you had this moment where you're like oh
maybe I can do this but then there's
just I didn't there's a thing of God you
go well what's next yeah you know
there's a lot of that usually what am i
doing next and then it's just so you
just go oh it's actually just a lot of
repetition yeah
there's actually no like there's no like
there's no set path okay and there's no
huge leaps either you know yeah I have a
moment where you like you book something
that's a huge leap but in the interim
you're just like I'm just doing shows I
always look at it as a ladder with
invisible rungs mm-hmm like to get to
that next step you don't even know where
it's at sometimes yeah like a climbing
wall yeah okay and then all of a sudden
you're on the neck oh you're okay I got
my footing on I didn't know what I was
there I always say my career is like a
like a treadmill set to one incline so
like I don't yeah so I don't even know
that I've done anything until I look
back oh I'll be right back we talked
about Jeremiah Wang yeah
so 30 minutes the singing do you want to
sound like Eric Griffin as I'm doing a
commercial for my class learn how to do
podcasting with Eric Griffin so so then
when did like something like really like
when did you start making a living
that's the real question
and so I went full-time with comedy in
2012 so I was I was pretty fortunate if
you look at it in the grand scheme of
things to get here in 2009 in July 2009
and in January of you know 2012 like I
was full time and I've had it you know
obviously with any comedian like you
have a lot of ups and downs like as far
as like some months are were like
incredibly hard but I'm very proud to
say that I've been doing it full-time
since 2012 going strong going strong and
it was a I booked a national commercial
that allowed me to leave Starbucks right
and I haven't since 2011 have not booked
a national sense it was like a three
spot national oh wow that's usually how
it works yeah you get like you know
switch when you first start when I first
started I booked a bunch of commercials
and then I haven't looked to commercial
in a while and I've been I coming close
I've been close for the last five years
I've been put on yeah a veil so many
times like 10 times in a row or
something like that everybody's still
break that streak no but it's like
everything all the callbacks are not he
was special they should just be called
all backs because they bring everybody
like what a [ __ ] do we do this first
audition right if you're gonna have 75
people here for the callback right and
then they put you on avails with it that
used to be special avails meant it used
to be that there's three guys in a row
and now there's like five or six ya know
five or six you yeah it's more than that
more than that yeah sometimes it'll be
like you know these are the nine people
were looking at it's like so everybody's
on avail this is so that business is
like going to [ __ ] oh I'll never forget
and I think I mentioned this on my
pockets but I'll mention it for your
listeners so I was super excited I was
doing I was doing a gig with you at like
the Bray Improv like years ago and
I was super excited I just got done
shooting a co-star like a like a two or
three line we're all in this pilot and
I'm so excited I'm coming to Eric you
know though the wise man in the room and
I'm like this was going and I'm so
excited my man Eric I'm so excited I
just worked on my first pilot and Erica
uh just like that you're like you're
like what's the name of this pilot I go
it's called untitled MV a project and
you look at me you go Jeremiah I don't
know how to tell you this if they don't
even have a name yet
that pilot ain't going yeah one month
later to the day what you just can't get
out picked up like in all the trades and
everything I does this business is so
with you can't really get excited about
anything no non tells actually out and
even the paycheck is in your hand yeah
but it's like even then it's like cuz
like I imagine you you're getting on a
show and you think okay this is gonna be
my income so you kind of you kind of get
your brain worked a certain way but you
can't even do that that's what I'm
saying yes because like you get that
pilot money it's just a pile of money
you can't quit you know you got you
still okay I gotta be frugal with this
well dude I bet I was so frugal with
that money that I made off that
commercial it paid my bills for one year
no good for you because I do it anymore
no because I knew I was like I have to
rely on this for my income for this
first year when you quit yeah I can't go
back because you probably quit like
[ __ ] saxophone out of here
[ __ ] um okay so then you were
so you gotta you know see your full-time
sort of comedian where you're like doing
commercials yeah it's doing like
commercial random gigs and a lot of like
hosting and featuring on the road yeah
yeah so which is hard you know like it's
so hard to make money like like income
like to pay your bills as a host or a
feature no it's like nearly impossible I
don't know it's and I always complain
about this
too late the comedy club owners and
things like that I just go how is the
comics of the future gonna be if you're
not supporting them now yeah you know
this is all they care about is like well
we gotta get this YouTube star in and or
whoever it is or what you know or the
largest comedians you don't mean yeah
you know the one percenters who sell the
places out everywhere you know yeah the
farming process is uh needs improve a
bit does me know it does for sure we
need we need our d-league you know so
but you've been doing that for a while
now and now you're doing your own thing
you know it's like you got a you know
you part of the roast battle you know
that yeah I've been part of the roast
battle for over five years now I know
it's crazy yeah it's wild and then you
think about that what do you actually
feel about that kind of stuff in the
comedy in the comedy game how do I feel
about like you know that show roast
battle and all that
I mean I'm super grateful to that show
it's opened a lot of doors for me but
it's one of those things where I'm at a
place now with my comedy and I go
through this all the time people know me
for my kind of ensemble roles on other
shows but a lot of people haven't seen
my stand-up and I'm like that's what I
do seven nights a week right so I'm
trying something yeah so I'm trying to
but a lot of my spots and stuff are
pretty late around town or whatever so
it makes sense that you know nobody even
still people are still gonna know you
for what you're most famous for right
like you know I was doing stand-up long
before I got on workaholics and then now
people just think I'm Montez and they
don't even know that I do stand-up yeah
so it's just a weird taste always trying
to get over that hurt that's just good
about doing podcast stuff like that
those cuz then we plug our dates in some
people
oh yeah I'll go see that I didn't I
wasn't even aware right I wanna go see
Montez do stand-up that's amazing yeah
yeah yeah so did you um so yeah I rose
petals been really good to me as as far
as that we did our third season the
third season in my opinion was not our
best we'll see if we come back no but I
was only there for half the season
because I was doing Just for Laughs new
faces and I was like like I got a yeah
you got I gotta go do that well I just I
don't know I mean I just feel like I
just feel like I wish they've made it
where
comedy isn't enough they've made it
where it's like it
works like it's so set oversaturated in
the market on Netflix and these places
where it's like they're doing like you
know here's 700 2-minute specials you
know all released on a Friday yeah I
mean so they've diluted the market you
know they you know preaching preaching
to the choir to this guy I have to do a
thousand things to get one of them going
you know what I'm saying that was like
so then now people look at stand-up and
they just go oh well they don't
appreciate just Dana so we have to know
we have to do we have to do roast battle
we had to do like some kind of extra
thing to like present comedy you know I
just well that's kind of funny most of
the the shows in LA if it's not a themed
show it doesn't sell tickets like I mean
you know I've been doing my show
stand-up on the spot over eight years
now yeah which you finally bid for the
first time I literally asked me properly
dude you are so difficult to lock down
for stuff you are dude um Bobby like I
swear like if you guys were easier like
to get ahold of like our friendship
would be on the next level I got it's
taking money for your wedding I'm here
you know I will say Eric has the title
of giving the best wedding gift
you literally gave the best wedding gift
oh good so there you go
I mean I don't know you got you know
roast battle and like you know and but
you're also part of a Tony hitch cliffs
podcast yeah kill Tony Tony that's a big
thing for you too yeah we tour with that
yeah you're part of the thing I gotta
tell you I gotta tell you you're great
on that like your level of commitment on
Tony's podcast is like like when I'm
sitting there and I'm looking at you
like just what the [ __ ] it's not gonna
break right now whatever character you
do yeah yeah I just think that's like
you know you're probably destined to be
on something like SNL or something like
I want to be in a sketch show I mean
that that I grew up being heavily
influenced by those shows and that's
what like got me into it and I would
love I'm in dream scenario with you but
don't say it in a way like you think
it's a pipe dream I don't think it's a
pipe dream I think it's very doable for
me to be on some sketch oven
may not be SNL but I think whether it be
my own sketch show or somebody else to
sketch show I think that's possible but
yeah that's something that I definitely
want to do because I mean I would love
to be able to do a sketch show and
tourist and up that would be like oh
yeah that's well that's the what the
dream is always I want to do this
and then tour States but I would venture
to say that I think that like which do
you think that you're a better at or
which do you think that you shine more
at you know I know you love to do
stand-up but I don't know I feel like as
I see you doing these other things I'm
like oh you are you this that's really
your really greatest goddamn Comedy Jam
you always wanna do a character on that
kill Tony the roast battle of the wave
and roast battle yeah so you're like
you'll you very much I got an ensemble
guy yeah we did we did we did midnight
snack for years with Joshua Meyers name
right you like riffs songs with us and
yeah all those are ensemble bass and
even stand up on the spot I recently
started taking suggestions with the
comics after their sets
well it's added a new energy and fun
that's you know I had a good time yeah
well speaking of characters on kill Tony
uh you know I actually think that one of
them actually showed up it's actually
one of your favorite character let me go
grab her oh my gosh I can't believe that
you you came prepared
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast feminist Stacy Wow
how long did it take for you to get a
woman on your show okay it's an odd
number it's easy
take care today huh Stacy it's always
pink feminist Eric Griffin I think
you're so big in your royal castle with
your brick wall and ooh I've been on TV
look at me oh here's my
specials subtly on the table right in
front of a guest yeah look it up the
ugly truth DVD you could buy it on my
website
Thank You feminist I'd also get it plug
I can't believe that you you brought
Jeremiah wonders to my listen there may
be saxophone playing later I don't know
but all I need I all I need for you to
know is that feminist Stacey is actually
a big fan of riffing with Griffith oh
really
yeah I love your voice my voice yes
so tell me an episode that you enjoyed
the most feminist station I like a lot
of the solo episodes where you really
just go off the rails that's a good
answer
so are you hear anything coming in the
pipeline would ya I'm vlogging
constantly what's the then this Stacey's
blog obviously obviously pretty simple
to search for on the Internet
just Stacy's blog no video no it's all
transcription of conversations that I
have so you better watch yourself mister
so there doesn't be a me-too moment at
living with Griffin wait so now let me
ask you so do you record the
conversation so you may be at Starbucks
you record the conversation recording
everything right now I know I'm on your
podcast but watch out mister I'm
recording you with my cellphone I can't
believe you did this to me then you
transcribe
then I transcribe it oh you're the work
you're the worst
legitimately you had a great moment a
guy at one of the shows and I said
something that you said something to me
and then all of a sudden you put that on
the internet I didn't yeah yeah you can
type it in on YouTube feminist AC yes
I'm gonna have to put that in the
description of episode will people can
really know who the dominant one is
and feminist Stacey is very um you know
are you dating I mean are you trying to
court
oh now I feel me - oh really well
finally you share the feeling that all
the women have you know what I've got to
go alright Eric Griffin alright yeah we
think that everybody thinks that
feminist Stacey were coming on then i
Stacey out like I can't believe
let's get Jeremiah back oh there he is
yeah I can't believe she interrupted the
show like that
I brought her she was been waiting in
the wings the whole time so I uh I
apologize uh but she can't be silenced
she's told me the head too many times
yeah she's told all of us that so many
times but as you can see there's a
classic example of Jeremiah's commitment
[Laughter]
Eric sees me roll up like outside his
place and I have like my sax and a bag
and was just like looking at me like are
you moving in don't worry I got some
surprises
guys he's like you're not bringing in
Jeremiah wonders there Riven with
Griffin I was like it'll be different we
just did it's two crossover episode I
know there's no phone call okay that was
one thing whenever you did my podcast
that so that's how he felt bamboozled as
I go I forgot to tell him because he's
one of the early episodes of my podcast
I was I think we're getting a phone call
and literally there's nothing in the
headphones Colin I'm like yeah you
totally that was that was the funniest
part about it I was like cuz in the
middle of it I'm like oh no he does this
this is yeah he's doing like no this is
so funny you're you're like you do Bain
[Laughter]
you do like a lot of different like you
have a lot of vocal control all right
people tell me this you do but I don't
notice it well it's because it's it
comes natural like no filters no but I
like in your stand-up and stuff like
I've watched like so many your sets in
stuff like that and you naturally do
sound effects I think where some people
whenever they do it it feels a little
forced onstage but that's just you is
this organic see yeah I just have a
weird way of uh I don't know I you know
what it's like I guess when you're doing
characters you know you know you just
feel like it's the best to just delve
into it like yes just to be as
vulnerable as possible you know cuz
sometimes sometimes are people who are
doing stuff they you're you're aware
that they are aware that they're doing
something yeah and for me I just like to
like I'm just you know yours flowing I'm
trying to become that thing all that so
going back to the the like whether I
prefer sketcher stand-up or whether I'm
better one that's kind of why I like
like I've been headlining like one night
or stuff like that I've done like some
occasional weekends like on smaller
markets I'm just now starting to do that
like in the last couple years and to me
that is like the best because that's me
you're getting to see me do my material
but I'm also riffing and stuff a lot and
I'm being do you bring stuff on stage
and all that no III don't bring that
understood you should man that's one
thing where I like to keep it separate
because I do so many different kinds of
shows like I don't want to be one of
those variety acts that I I see but you
putting a label on it you see this is
the thing see this is this is so
interesting that you say this it's funny
because I was talking to Jerrod
Carmichael today you know and it's like
he never wants to do anything that
anyone else is doing yeah you know it's
always he won't always wants to be
authentic to him mhm you know and it's
like pushing the envelope you outside
the box so you're saying that about like
oh I want to be a variety act but
there's not a lot of variety acts yeah
like it's not but it's not a variety act
it's you like it's like so knit like
what you just did
was just so natural for you that you
just like I totally could see you doing
that on stage I told you can see you
being like you know you're at your stone
you're like hey guys oh my god you know
who's here I can't believe and then you
just do it and you'll be surprised how
people are gonna like you know that's
different like you don't got to do stand
up like I do stand up right cuz it's
gonna be like how can people tell the
difference how are you gonna shine as
you yeah that's a good point that's all
I'm saying man yeah cuz then you don't
cuz in it like you have you gonna have
your sax you're gonna have your thing
you're gonna have everything that you
want to do and you're still doing your
material and it just becomes like a show
that people are gonna enjoy watching as
opposed to like just another for
instance another white guy on stage like
tellin jokes like you know what makes
you different I don't know I'm just I'm
just throwing that out there at you uh
you know no maybe maybe one of these
headlining shows where I'm just like I
don't gotta be like Harry basil and like
you you know you where you got like a
trunk and all over yeah I think that's
what I'm I don't want to get I guess I
don't want to get labeled as a prop
comic you know what I mean yeah like but
but like but again as opposed to being
labeled as what like what's the
alternative I don't know just a stand-up
comic Yeah right right but then like so
then there's plenty of those there's
plenty of those yeah you didn't mean
like what makes somebody different
you know what makes you not even
different but unique to you mm-hmm
you know I don't know I think you might
I don't know I just think you might
shine more I think you might it might be
the thing that makes you unique
maybe over everyone else maybe that's
the missing puzzle piece it could be I
don't know yeah I mean yeah the beauty
of doing it like when you go on the road
is like who cares like you know you like
do it yeah you should do an experiment
and see what happens I bet the first I
guarantee you the first time you do it
the first time you're on stage and you
put that feminist Stacy wig on and you
start doing your thing you're gonna feel
more yourself than anything that you've
ever done because it's like you know
it's like it's difficult when we're
writing these jokes you know right you
know what I hate and it's like you
construct an act you're doing it some
[ __ ] happens in the crowd right and
somebody does something you start
interacting with that then after the
show people go oh man the best part of
the show is we
you did that see what the dude I [ __ ]
hate that because in my mind I'm like I
wrote an act yeah I brought a show and
you're trying to tell me that your
favorite part was when I rift on the
dude that was being an ass yeah that's
like oh that's so when I went that
because I'm very conversational with the
crowd and I rift with the crowd a lot
like I get that a lot like even in
longer sets like pure like when you did
that one thing with the audience member
of mine I didn't I spent no time do I
know that's just like me like well that
just tells you like for me it always
makes me go I got it I gotta work on my
performance I got to make sure that my
performance has that same organic know
that same energy this is like that's a
I've buried myself with too good a crowd
work like before like if you go too hard
like at the top of your set and then
like cuz you're doing a magic show
essentially yeah yeah yeah and then
you're like okay and then they can tell
you're going in the script of material
then they're like tell you though I
would tell you about like you know it's
like sounding like you're you're you're
being too scripted yeah but that's just
what happens when you like you know you
write a joke you you're not sure why
it's funny mm-hmm you think it's funny
for these reasons and then you start
like just doing it that way and then it
just becomes robotic and like you know
stale yeah as opposed to like you know
your personality generally is it's
ejected and ya supposed to like how do
you feel about stuff so I mean yes it's
an interesting thing like on the journey
on the journey of stand-up like where do
you think you are on it like where do
you feel like you're what level do you
think you're at on the stand up for you
for my stand up I feel like I'm really
developing right now what I want my like
one hour to be you know what I mean like
I have like I have realistically I've
got an hour and a half to an hour forty
of different material with no riffing
but my ideal sets when I am being me on
stage and I do super low sets I do about
40 minutes of material and 20 minutes of
interacting and riffing and Sariah
so I don't know so
ya know what you're saying cuz I even
feel like I feel like even with my
standup I'm still I'm still trying to
get to like another level
it's just weird I think yeah I think I
mean being funny is like be funny is not
hard for me you know yeah hard to be
funny but it's like what I realize is
that's not enough that doesn't make you
memorable it doesn't make you like like
it's like I don't know it's like do I
wanna have something to say a point of
view or is it my thing just being like
you know just like oh I'm gonna say this
crazy thing that's on my mind or like a
push the envelope but even still I think
like I think what we're all searching
for it's like a way to like have this
cohesive yeah I'm trying to get more
personal all the time because that's for
me because I have a lot of zany wacky
bits the personal stuff sometimes hits
as hard or harder because people are
like oh this is like real and I can
relate to this more then or it could be
it also could be just the way you're
performing the personal stuff just that
it's just that alone and just like when
you start talking about yourself and
when you start getting into like these
like vulnerabilities we tend to like be
more loose and free in that way so I
guess the real trick in stand-up is
making our material feel like that yeah
you know yeah I don't know cuz I think
that you have all this stuff but I think
that this thing we're talking about it
might it might even open you up even
more yeah I'll give it a shot I mean I'm
dude you know me I'm always down to
experiment so okay today old school
teacher Eric Griffin is coming in
alright alright everybody we've got some
stuff to learn so being on kill Tony
I've done that a few times
um yeah you're the the only honorary
guess what killed Jeremiah oh that's
right yeah well you did kill Jeremiah
that was funny what do you think of the
podcasting world right now especially
all the people that we know I think it's
cool to be a part of this group like
that that's it's it's it's cool what's
happening right now I think just like
everything else I think there's gonna be
a bubble that kind of burst with it
there's gonna be over saturation but
right now I mean we're kinda in the
golden era Pot
Cass works I know dude like the fact
that we know everybody who has like all
the huge podcast this is cool
like we see them go up we see them work
out their jokes and then we see their
podcast become successful and blow up
and stuff but here's the ironic part
though man there's actually bigger
podcasts yeah there's actually people
out there this is what I'm saying I
don't know if the bubbles gonna burst
because it's such a direct-to-consumer
thing that that there is no worry about
like if you put on an NBC show NBC has
to make sure that the sponsors are happy
true that people are buying these things
so that it really is predicated on that
and then so they so do we get viewership
it's a weird relationship right for us
it's strictly however many viewers it is
those are your fans you know and like
they're watching all they're watching
numerous podcasts on their own time I
mean there's a lot of really huge
podcasts out there people that we just
have no we don't know them well there's
a lot of yeah there's a lot of non
comedy podcast talk about even comedy
podcasts oh yeah
oh yeah man that's what I'm saying like
when used to be I didn't realize it
that's what I'm saying
oh man well of course we know the
biggest one ever is Joe Rogan right I
mean like Jill's podcasters you have
four million subscribers and yeah I mean
the Reach is so powerful and like but
again it's so direct to consumer you
know like I did his podcast and then
that weekend I went to Irvine and it was
like I never had that many numbers yeah
and people just walking up should be
like oh man Joe Rogan that was good no
it's better than a TV appearance I mean
it's a crazy yeah career room so they
also on the late-night shows uh somebody
that this this is what could cause
podcasting could cause the late-night
shows to eventually crumble because
we're having a real conversation right
now and you can't have that only night
show it's all stick and like this is
some idiot Booker trying to construct
your set right that's just part I can't
stand is like okay we won't want you to
do that one joke from what you call it's
like hey man nobody's watching your show
yeah so get the [ __ ] out of my face you
didn't mean these people act like their
cars Carson there's 80 million people
watch yeah yeah yeah no one's watching
sound like Tony now Tony tells you that
all the time yeah it's it's it's
craziness though it's absolutely crazy
like you could I could do a late night
set I you could do a late night set on
Monday right and have a show the next
day same amount of people are gonna show
up but you do like fighter in the kid
Joe Rogan Bobby Lee's podcast you do any
of those people's things and the number
of people that are gonna be more
invested it's like so they need to like
even look at conan man
Conan's upon his podcast killing it like
if he asked if he said to you like hey
can you come on my show you might be
like so it's a crazy man podcasting is
blowing up I feel like podcasting is the
new do comedy cuz you're like all these
actors and actresses or whoever you know
they were famous as whatever and then
like 10 years ago they were like oh I'm
gonna be a comic cuz I can sell out
that's what their ages the agents were
like ya know you can sell on a comedy
club if you start doing comedy yeah now
they're just doing podcasts yeah you
know what's interesting though is a lot
of the actor types when they go on these
comedy podcasts it doesn't like move the
needle like the listeners like a gnarly
it's weird it's like they want their
podcast comics on there you know I'm
kind of having such a weird time with
this trying to figure out what people
want so as you know so many people
through the acting side decide if you
have to build I guess I have to build my
brand because it's difficult because a
lot of the people to listen to my
podcasts are like Tiger belly fans
mm-hmm so they just want to see Bobby
and his brother all the time every day I
get a hit you know what they get a Kubek
on and those are my largest episodes so
that tells me that those there's a
contingent like a large portion of my
numbers are because of them so then I
realize oh I have to build other other
things yeah you know what I mean but
it's like and then because they don't
like at Tiffany Haddish on you know that
wasn't a big episode yeah you know I
mean it's crazy yeah it's where I Haven
had Dane Cook you know I was one of the
first people that have I had Dame on my
podcast first you know and then I'm
thinking how I got to exclusive three
days later to some [ __ ] on
Thea's podcast with makeup on and I hear
a head get his hair done like what the
[ __ ]
he came with a hat and it was like la
what now he's like mr. podcast guy so I
can see you deceive it was still a huge
it was still a huge you know for me yeah
like for instance he was just on what's
the mother's house which was to mom's
house at Mom's house yeah he just was on
that and he isn't just a clip from that
has a million hits have you watched that
clip it's a great clip I know it's yeah
he but he tells that story yeah so
annoying
it's like anyway but what I'm saying is
yeah that's the thing about podcasting
is you have to find your finding your
audience yeah for sure and that's what I
love about it though I love the people
that walk up to me and they're like Amen
love version with Griffin that's such a
real flow because those are your real
real and I appreciate you all up yeah
that say that to me
you know you know but it's like but
again you're it's like if I go on your
podcast and then so that there's a few
Jeremiah Wonder fans and maybe like me
oh let's go watch that
yeah vice versa cuz I've had people ask
me about your you being on yeah yeah
I've had people be like you gotta get
your my walk is on my burner account is
so [ __ ] seven troll accounts yeah
they're all just like Prolia
Jeremiah but she does those ones you
know how it's like I it's like
Jeremiah's my husband Jeremiah you know
you know how do you do therefore like
Bieber yeah yeah I know but I just feel
like the podcasting market is it's such
a such a we're in the Wild West right
now for what what what it can be or what
it would be right yeah I mean is it do
you feel like your success recently is
directly related to like all the
podcasts the me started my own podcast
like I've I've been doing that podcast
for a Bandhan Jeremiah wonders for
a year and five months now oh geez and
that starting that along with kill Tony
has been like I've been super grateful
like like dude I've been given two
saxophones since then oh wow
like like this sax that that I have over
here like I show it show it I was gonna
say that's beautiful oh yeah it's all of
the the freaking look at the colors on
that bad boy yeah
what does that stainless steel early
what what is that I just love how it
that matted weld like gunmetal gun I
don't they call this they call this
saxophone the Raven oh Jesus yeah so
there there is a I put it out there on
my podcast and on kill Tony I was like
hey I've been playing the same sax since
I was in grade school like this like
that I used to rent you know and like
literally like yeah I feel like I've
been driving the same car you on if
you're listening we were joking but
something like that could totally happen
I mean I the the the listeners who have
responded when I've just offhandedly
said like I need something I'm super
grateful somebody bought me a laser
printer because like my printer was
acting up there like I'll send you a
printer Wow
like that's great it's so I'm super
grateful with riffin fans get your [ __ ]
together [ __ ] is going on with you you
like you got some dope music that you
know I really do I really have some like
really you have to turn it on
you know you pump the Ripley he's gonna
go to second mic just without a need
without heat without any provocation I
didn't know that you had to know I used
to know there's a switch and then you
know why because I had one of these and
it was bleedin and yes it was yeah
you're like what is that yeah so I was
like this is what I do ma'am I having a
stroke the entire singing sax time y'all
singing with Jeremiah very talented
[Music]
you know I will say this I don't know if
I like your evil eye you give why you
play the saxophone like that actually
got to tell you we had a great
we had a great little moment together
cuz when I was on the goddamn Comedy Jam
with you and you know we did a careless
whispers dude but like when we went to
Jay a felon did it in front of like what
was i five thousand people whatever it
is my mom actually like she sent me that
she was like so you with Jeremiah
Watkins she's a no like nothing she
doesn't know but not to say that you're
not that but she's on YouTube like air
Griffin to Jeremiah watch my walk it
must be the deal on a freaking Jumbotron
that was great that was wild dude they
said that like almost 10,000 people were
there really went all the way back oh
Jesus Christ
yeah for my first concert yeah that was
fun though but I was crazy but I was so
sick of doing that song though cuz ya
kept you know what I mean it does crush
like people were freaking out lyrica
yeah yeah we there first and it got
literally a woman I've never seen this
at a comedy show a woman threw her
panties at Erica you seen Careless
Whisper like I picked them up I was like
oh so you're and you okay let's talk
about this now you're married yeah I'm
married
no you I'm always teasing you about
being married yeah yeah well you're such
but this is the Kansas in you this is a
Christian this is the Kansas boy was
like because you were telling me like
leading up to you're like what are you
doing what are you doing you know what
it is though is because like you know we
spend a lot of time at the Comedy Store
together but people don't really know
what's going on in people's personal
life sure like you know you're dating
you you've been you're dating yeah you
were dating her for a while yeah we
never see her you know you're not the
kind of brings her around a lot
everybody's different everything is
different like like on like how personal
they kind of let people in and that's
one side of things like I literally just
on Instagram
the late last week posted a picture of
my wife
oh wow I was for like she has a book
coming out and I wanted to her I didn't
know that
yeah let's talk about that real fast
it's uh it's called zip zap zop the
brains playground oh she's my college's
she'd basically what she does is she
uses improv as a tool to teach kids on
the autism spectrum and with special
needs improv to help with their social
skills Wow yeah she you already knew you
had a good one but that's even that
takes it to another level
yeah she's giving back and she and she's
cool with you being in the entertainment
business she she's the best super
supportive we met originally like she I
met her at an improv class oh wow at
Second City Oh years ago like back in
like 2010 yes were you improv me that
you were in a relationship no but we had
we had bloody no funny if you were like
you're proud that you were married I
mean you guys only had scenes at some
point where we were dating or married or
something because we did like countless
improv scenes together in class stuff
like that
did you like improv doing improv I love
him probably you do love that's your
thing i but here's the thing
bad improv is so much worse than bad
stand-up oh because it might my friend I
think my buddy Chris Edwards put it
perfectly he goes would you see a
stand-up comedian having a bad set
that's one person failing when you see a
bad impression that sag Rupe of people
failing together and continuously
failing yeah oh it's it's nice brutal
hey I can't stand it you know but I do
have you ever like guested like with a
like an actual good team no I'm like a
celebrity guest or so I was going to
yeah actually in Chicago because they
would set you up perfectly like that's
what they do
like good improvisers if you guest with
them they
exactly how to make you shine and how to
make you look good and it's fun but when
you're working with people who don't
know what they're doing it's a train
wreck and then you're just scrambling
the entire time I've been in the
situation like that cause I'm proud when
I first was in the business I got a
chance to be Robert Townsend was doing
this like show he wanted to do this show
and it was gonna be called singing fools
and it was singing with improv you know
like not half and half so you would sing
then it was like also impressed us so I
remember doing an improvised musical
yeah yes acerra Lee okay
it was more like it was gonna be a
sketch show so we're doing sketches but
at the same time we're also they're also
they have like it never listened it was
never gonna make it to air okay cuz this
is I can't even explain it probably it
was so stupid you know I mean yeah but I
remember we were doing like as a
rehearsing and we're like doing these
improv that this I'm doing this improv
this gun I'll never forget he was my
boss and the improv and he fired me like
where do we go from here bro where do we
go how about you review my performance
instead of just firing me just like Sony
pulled out a gun back yeah you're done
which is the funny thing in the office
he just keeps with young people do ok
Brees not bringing that up was um what I
did I did The Groundlings I did it a
great deal like a beginner class yeah as
I wanted to do it because I felt like
improv would help my stand-up yeah this
only reason why I always recommend
improv it really do it really is it's a
skill skill like different muscle but
it's like it's like a shooting drill but
it shouldn't be a show you get what I'm
saying
like I wouldn't pay to go the Staples
Center to see people shoot free throws
yeah that's to me what improv is but is
a very important skill but my thing at
first when I was young it was like all
my improv with sexual funny enough
that's where my my wife went a lot of
times like she would take it there
sexually and it would kill because she
has this like very sweet boy
like you don't see it coming out like
literally
hi justno no reason to go to the singing
my but the singing mic for no reason I
like it me and wait you know what I
gotta turn that every time every time
you bump the the thing it sounds like a
Christopher Nolan film who's that
[ __ ] idiot everything
hey man you know I also think it's a
overrated producers we're talking about
that is uh this Star Wars guy John
Williams is that his name the composer
the composer is that right John Williams
I don't know who he is but this is
almighty right all his songs sound the
same I like Danny Elfman and he's gotten
like you know 10 Oscars but literally
they're all the same Superman that's
Superman
Star Wars is uh you know they're all the
same and he got an Oscar for everything
one of them I don't understand that you
know but shout out kudos to him
good for you I like I like Danny Elfman
what was his things he'd like he's a
he's done everything from like comedy
movies to drama where and then also he
did like the soundtrack to one of the
early Batman movies oh he's good Oh God
to look him up guys hook him up classic
composer classic composer dude we've
been talking for like over an hour yeah
we really yeah it doesn't feel like it
right you gotta have this thing of my
god what are you doing man you gotta
have the singing my god you went to that
didn't go to this thing in might and
whatever well there you go you turn it
on I like that but I cut that out oh
yeah keep it for that one reference it
pops so that I take that out but now I
have to keep it in because there's that
one in yeah the most soulful white guy
around everybody Jeremiah Watkins those
soulful sounds of Jeremiah anytime I'm
on a lineup there people have not seen
me or don't know me they always think
I'm a black guy always yeah it sounds it
Watkins is yeah but the Jim did Jeremiah
I don't know I thought that would throw
them throw me off that's going their way
yeah if you go Mormon or it can go and
they just black family that's true
that's true yeah Jeremiah named Jeremiah
Watkins Watson would be even more but no
Jeremiah Watkins did your wife take your
last name she did yeah oh I'm surprised
yeah well she's old school too right
is she like she's where she from
Northern California oh well yeah it's
kind of conservative up there really
yeah did you was that the thing you
wanted to happen what hard to take your
last name did it matter to you I think I
did yeah I think like I think probably
the Kansas in May was like that means
like I mean did you backhander I mean
feminist states you would have a thing
yeah okay let's finish off with I just
wanna know what you're watching
what are you watching right now on TV
what's wrong yeah and watching watching
Game of Thrones what do you think of
that last the the second to last episode
from last night can I ruin this one on I
don't know when this is gonna come out
when this comes out game with those
would be over okay cool I just want to
make sure yeah game what those would be
over by the time this one comes out then
but this last step is why I just didn't
like it uh that turn she burned the
whole [ __ ] City well like all this
she's the mad queen all of a sudden well
that's what it kind of felt like a
little phoned in on the writing side bro
I was I was like you're doing this to a
character that we've long had been
falling for for so long we've been
following in her first six seasons like
the whole point of this is I want to see
her sit on that iron throne and there's
peace in the realm yeah and you're
naturally gonna do it the wrong way
the whole city yeah it was kind of I
would have preferred her burn to keep
down well that's what I didn't
understand I was like if you're gonna go
crazy why not just go straight to Cersei
land that dragon no but that's not evil
she wanted to be yeah she was like no no
because these people supported her
that's why I just I'm out okay like I'm
out oh yeah I'm done like I like the
show yeah I'm done because the first
three episodes were so good that
build-up and by the way that battle with
the night king that should have been the
last episode I should have been the last
what that's done already you mean
they've been walk-in in the winter for
[ __ ] seven seasons and then they
finally give here in the battles like
this practically it would have been a
better season finale to just have the
night king bed and then we're left to
not know and how about this what happens
what best thing about this show is when
the the evil people when we see them get
it that's what pissed me off about
Circe's you're not gonna slit her throat
or see me but the baby I wanna see as a
game of Thrones fan but that was
frustrating to me she's still alive like
the rubble I think they're still alive
I pray that they're still alive first of
all in the show like I don't know how
Arya survived like every scene is like
oh she got burned - oh she did oh yeah
building our building didn't fall on her
it was like you know it just the angle
is like how that to me bad filmmaking
well did you hear the behind the city
did you watch do you watch the behind
the scenes thing that they play after
yeah the writers literally said well
they didn't have a good explanation on
why Arya other than like her like you
know going to kill cares it's going to
kill Cersei why she was like they're
like why she was on the ground level the
reason why they said that they wanted to
follow her was because it would just be
more relatable no no I'm the audience
I enjoyed the choice that they were
making see this is what I'm okay check
this out they don't realize what they
did they actually made us hate Dany even
more by doing it that way
oh absolutely like it like if they would
have just
with her and then like you know she got
scorned by jealous just like I don't
want to [ __ ] my aunt anymore okay yeah
like you can't understand that but also
are you slightly mad at John that he if
he would have just had sex with her one
more time I know I know what is saved
yeah but he's too honorable I know but
this mouth how many times has John
gotten in trouble because he's too
honorable he's ruined everything with
that yeah actually yeah he shouldn't
have told Sansa and Arya no he should
have just like you know he should have
first of all he should have just been
like yeah she'd be the king cuz you know
like why tell her he should have told
Annie she is my queen
yeah she is who I want to serve forever
yeah it's just weird man
I just I they've lost me at because it
would I feel like I feel like the the
creator's have lost me cuz I feel the
laziness of this app this season Twitter
is saying that Game of Thrones is
pulling a lost on us where they don't
know it's so scattered for they don't
know because this is way past how far
the books have been ready in this game
he's just sitting there cashing checks
here's your [ __ ] you know he's probably
I'll see you in Reno excuse me that's
two R's thank you can you rewrite this
yeah can you uh sorry
yeah I don't know man I'm interested to
see how the house is gonna end watch
Barry doing I don't want to watch Barry
you got to get into Barry I'll check
Barry I see it I see it every time I
look bro cuz veep is over so I just saw
the final episode of only 30 minute
episodes you don't get too invested I
check it fly by and also watch and tell
me other things you watch it there's
another show called I think you should
leave as a sketch show on Netflix Zena
Tim Robinson wrote records
he's a former writer and cast member on
SNL oh wow
and he's super he was like too weird for
SNL but he's like perfect for the
vehicle yeah because he gets to be like
so outrageous and there's a bunch of
like other people from like mad strictly
watch comedy like that or what do you
know I also watched documentaries with
my wife is so bad I just I just watched
three identical strangers what's going
on one and not
I like documentaries a lot it's about
these three different men who find out
that they are actually triplets and
they've never met before they were there
they grew up in different cities and
they get national recognition because
they get reunited right and at the end
this a big reveal of why why they were
separated hmm and it's really
interesting what's the name of three
identical strange radical strangers yeah
I'm not a documentary guy
Bobby's got me into a lot it's not that
I don't like documentaries and just I
just don't go to because I get out I'll
be in a rabbit hole you know cuz my
problem with documentaries is like I
can't just stop there I have to then I
go online and be like what really
happened right you know cuz I don't
believe that communities my point about
what I'm trying to say is that now when
I watch documentaries I find myself
going well let me let me find out if
what they're saying is true or is there
another side you know yeah especially
any Michael Moore documentary any
Michael Moore you got to look at both
sides yeah but that's the beauty of like
the the Internet is an accompaniment to
documentaries yeah there's all these
conspiracy theories and stuff like that
you can check out them like no because
the way they don't the way they present
documentaries like you think oh man cuz
look at making a murderer okay making a
you ever see making tomorrow yeah oh
yeah I was I was I was infuriated I was
mad with the second season I didn't I
don't you know what I didn't even watch
the 2nd season watch the first episode
in the last episode you know why I
didn't watch it
mmm because they're still in jail yeah
so I was like I don't I'm out because
all that evidence and everything that
went on in that first season of how they
documented everything for those people
to still be in jail tells me that
there's more to the story I mean that's
the only thing I can that's my well
that's some of the press releases and
stuff that of the people like the DA and
stuff like that we're interviewed after
the fact the documentary they're like
they didn't cover this this and this and
that's what I'm saying
so I'm say so the way the documentary is
presented you'd be like these people
shouldn't be in jail even though I don't
even though what they already showed for
that kid Brendan whatever his name been
and I see for Brendan
did that was the most heart-wrenching
wouldn't you're badgering him yeah and
then he says okay when I found toes in
the fire and he says that he says can I
go back to school it's like he has no
idea there's no ID you just admitted to
[ __ ] capital murder well but you get
going you're not going to school yeah
can you imagine this is that interview
he's never been back to school I know
this is what I'm saying where I look at
you know I look at documents rough and
I'm like I'm like I need to like I need
to investigate further so that's why I
don't necessarily watch watch a lot of
documentaries cuz I go down the rabbit
hole but I do like watching
documentaries about someone's story like
those are interesting too
yeah like Bobby's keeps making me watch
this one about the guy that mountain
climbs you know the guy those free
climber guys know ropes and it
supposedly really like it's like you
know scary just what you see the guy do
so yeah III mean I'm gonna I want to get
into some more documentaries but I like
watch the shows two men Bobby got me
into documentaries more and then he's
actually the reason I got into Game of
Thrones
oh really I was on the road with him and
he paid me to watch Game of Thrones so
we could talk about it on the road yeah
I love talking to Bobby
it was split dinner the other night we
could talk Game of Thrones for us oh
yeah yeah but he watches all the
episodes multiple times yeah you have to
sometimes and then but these like I said
I'm out I did they like I'm just like
the last season for me was the last
season you know cuz they just it's so
lazy the fact that there's only six
episodes right tells me that they're
stretching like what are you doing six
episodes for this iconic show you can't
finish the season off right with the
episode who knows maybe like by the time
this comes out that sixth episode will
have redeemed whatever
I hope so we'll see you next week and
our timeline yeah next week you know I
mean just like Avengers end game where
it's like a different time yeah I love
that I did you yeah oh I loved it too it
was great yeah it was really good that
it was the like the people who had to go
when you know yeah yeah yeah like I was
like they can't all just come back like
this is not yeah that would be whack
yeah but I but I loved it I also the
multiverse ideas I love all that you
watch the show flash
no I started to I like Supergirl okay I
haven't seen Supergirl I've watched like
a bunch of C's as a flash I'm not caught
up with the most recent season but
there's a lot of multiverse and
alternate timelines cuz flash has been
on Supergirl yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
like in their universe it was like I'm
in this other universe and I was like I
totally can get that yeah it would make
sense cool especially time-travel would
have to be like that yeah you know but I
thought in game handled the time-travel
great I enjoyed endgame I mean I'm on
you know I'm enjoying all this I want to
see that new x-men movie that's coming
out see how they Hamlet Dark Phoenix oh
I haven't seen the trailer for that yet
what wears nothing under a rock I want
to see it to it there's a part two to
that yeah I didn't like the first one
really yeah - stranger things II uh well
you know with these kids it's like oh
the smartest wittiest kids you know the
nerdy smart witty kids did you watch the
original Stephen King no I haven't
watched that one so strange things is
kind of doing the it thing I know you
know what I mean yeah like so that like
that came out as like a TV movie years
ago and a two-parter and my brother and
I told my sister that it was a comedy
about clowns and she's still afraid to
come yeah so what do you think about did
you ever did you see Umbrella Academy on
Netflix no I've heard good things up
yeah you got to watch down yeah there's
so many [ __ ] to watch so much so I can't
I know your recommendations list they'll
be like Oh giant giant Gondar ginormous
but but anyways um let's get out of here
we Kiki I'm gonna have you won again
because we could just keep talking and
talking and talking I see so why don't
we uh you want to go out on some sax
play Yeah right yeah could I uh could I
do a quick plug or something before we
go but that's just exactly what I'm
about to say so like give me all your
information what's next for you and
let's uh go out go out on a bang here
alright so uh the Reagan Watkins album
my debut music comedy album Oh
On June 7th on all platforms I'll have
I'll have all this in the description
and it's it's available for pre-order
now we're gonna try to get it one number
one on iTunes so if you like music
comedy go check it out yeah this guy's
one of the best very talented musician
and then at Jerry - stand up on social
media and Jeremiah Watkins comm for tour
dates and all that stuff great
youtube.com slash Jeremiah Watkins and
Eric Griffin's gonna be appearing on
Jeremiah wonders again yeah yeah and if
you see you know Jeremiah on the road
maybe he'll be doing some new uh some -
new improv on there so ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
yeah
[Laughter]